a common theme that I see in my comment
section of people saying that they want
to study physics but they're too bad at
maths to do so and I thought I'd share a
few thoughts on this idea one is that
you don't need to be a mathematical
genius to study physics or to be a
physicist yes maths is an important tool
for physics but it's not the most
important thing the most important thing
is wanting to understand physical
phenomena and maths is really just the
tool you're going to use to do that you
don't need to be the absolute top of
your class and that's in fact all you
need is to have those basics of maths
down so things like basic algebra and
calculus and an understanding of how we
can describe things through equations
mainly like this sort of rigorous maths
that you're going to a sort of approach
is mainly going to be used to get you
through your coursework unless you want
to specialize in theoretical or really
maths based physics after that it's
entirely possible that even if you do
really sort of hate maths and don't want
to do it for a career that once you use
maths to get through your coursework you
can specialize in an area of physics
maybe more experimental that doesn't use
so much of those math skills but be
careful in saying that you hate maths
and and one thing to get away from it or
from letting it hold you back because I
think that you probably aren't as bad at
maths as you think you are especially if
your math skills are from what's being
assist in high school it's very easy to
confuse sort of real maths which is a
way to describe the universe with
arithmetic which is adding numbers
together and sort of memorizing things
and memorizing equations and sort of
what you're going to be assessed on at
school especially in early years of
maths at school arithmetic is not used
in physics and in fact plenty of
physicists hate arithmetic I was at a
dinner the other night with a bunch of
physics PhD students and physics
professors and when it came time to
split the bill the calculator came
straight out because that's not what you
do in higher level maths and in high
level physics it's no longer about
adding numbers together it's a
understanding trends and numbers and the
way things change I've not always been
the most confident in my own max
abilities I've not always been and I'm
not still like the most fluent and
that's I always need to give myself a
reminder at the start of every semester
say about exactly how these certain
tools are are used and how they work but
as long as you know how to teach
yourself everything like that as you go
that's all you need you don't need to
memorize hundreds of techniques and ways
to solve problems and you don't need to
know every mathematical approach you
just need to be able to find the one
that you need at the time I have friends
that studied physics with me that that
agree that that would top of their class
and Max and that have picked it up as
they go along I have one close friend in
particular who told me that at high
school he was placed in the class for
people who are bad at maths and that I
only sort of taught that bare minimum to
catch up but he managed to claw his way
out of there and graduate with a physics
degree so even if you're in a similar
situation right now you just need to be
able to claw your way out of people that
don't believe in your maths skills I
think if you're at the stage where
you're considering what you should
pursue as a career or changing majors
then you're young enough to be able to
intentionally reshape your own brain to
learn that
and that's probably going to be a
journey that you have to take just go
forwards and immerse yourself in physics
this will buy as a byproduct immerse you
in mathematics in the way that it is
actually useful by doing physics you
encounter mathematics as you need it and
I think that's okay learn it as you go
and and don't worry about getting too
far ahead of yourself once you see the
context of how mathematics is useful I
think you'll learn to appreciate it more
and seeing that use may help you
understand it in a wider in a wider
context and become better at it so
practice your max practice it in context
of of the physics that you're doing and
I'm confident that you'll get better so
good luck